welcome to your mom's house
I just wanted to think about it a little
bit
I mentioned the movie that I narrated is
out the other name so I can pull up the
film I narrated it's it's out and them
you know festivals and whatnot it's
called can we take a joke mm-hmm
I'm the narrator Gilbert Godfrey Lisa
Lampanelli Penn Jillette is in it and
it's about the how political correctness
is destroying the comedy world pretty
interesting stuff and did you know that
there's a comedian being sued right now
in Canada I sure did yeah so it's just
heartbreaking and it has a really strict
law about saying fuck boys and making
fun of people and boy that's really lame
I love you Canada but that's lame yeah I
feel like I could have fuckin a few
times I've been there where I could have
got in trouble yeah yeah because he made
fun of that guy in Canada made fun of a
disabled yes a person yeah little boy
yeah I went to sing for the Pope or
something yeah and the line was like you
know I didn't expect that kid to live
long and he ended up living yes upset
who cares whatever
I mean I'm joke but it's something like
when I did my my conjoined twins but I
feel like that could have been taken in
Canada I know it's terrifying if I have
the right to say anything you certainly
have the right to be offended if I sit
can say anything I want you can say Penn
shouldn't have said that and you can say
Penn shouldn't have said that none of us
should talk to him anymore and pension
has said that we shouldn't have a job
and pension has said that and he's not
funny
Penn should have said that we're gonna
put a pickets out in front of the club
and he should be able to go to that club
all of that is within your rights and
very clearly within your rights but just
like every individual has to make a
decision on just because they can say
something doesn't mean they have to say
it individuals have to make the decision
that just because you might feel
offended by something doesn't mean you
have to announce you're offended yeah
so there you go it's a really really
timely documentary it's it's where these
guys started making it right and it's
all kind of exploded since then they
covered that story about that woman who
tweeted as she was on her way to South
Africa yes I hope I don't get a it's
just kidding I'm white and not the
greatest joke but who cares and she
ended up losing her job yeah she ended
up having to change her name they
couldn't even get her to be in the
documentary because she's like I'm not
fucking touching the subject again I got
into so much trouble over a tweet I feel
like this is such a cool gig for you to
get good Sue's the best not only is it
the cool gig of narrating something
which is a good gig
but this topic every basically every
comedian feels this way about it and
you're the voice of the film yeah I'm so
I'm so private Ted baliker did it so
here's a little write-up in Maxim a new
documentary can we take a joke presents
us with their side of the issue directed
by Ted bile Carr narrated by comedian
christina pazsitzky did I say it right
the film shows how luminaries like
Gilbert Godfrey Penn Jillette Lisa
Lampanelli Adam Carolla Jim Norton
Heather McDonald have grappled with this
trend in American culture spoiler alert
they're not too thrilled about it looks
like it's been doing well at the fit the
fest reviews are great it's it's I don't
know yet how to see it but it's called
can we take a joke I think it just
debuted it's really cool I can't wait I
haven't seen it I haven't seen it with
my narration in it but I've seen it in
like the the raw as I was narrating it
so it's it's so cool I mean this would
be clearly timely thing two comedians
basically feel the way that Penn just
mentioned there that's basically
summarizes yeah which is that you have
the right to feel any way you want to
feel about a joke but it's the idea that
you're feeling that way outweighs
everything else that is outrageous
yeah you know well and also like to have
your feelings hurt it's fine but hurt
feelings don't warrant people losing
their
jobs yeah I'm like that woman I tweeted
something okay yeah we get it it's
really racially insensitive but did she
deserve to lose her livelihood and have
it ruin her life cuz she said something
she said without thinking she was trying
to be funny and failed like it wasn't
she wasn't inciting violence against
people or playing clips that are like
hey Hitler you know what I mean like she
wasn't doing those things right right
like Gilbert Gilbert lost his job as the
Aflac okay Aflac voice because meats
joke tweet you know they're they're
obviously not the sweetest tweets but
that's you know he's a comedian that's
what he's known for
and he's a comedian who is known for
being cantankerous and saying crazy shit
so they want the guy who's not gonna say
that don't hire Gilbert as your Erica
it's so corny like yeah anyway you're
gonna it's they cover a lot of other
examples of what's happening especially
on college campuses which is kind of
really alarming because that's supposed
to be where you debate ideas yeah of all
kinds and now there's a resistance even
debating ideas that are considered
politically there's also this movement
of I've seen amongst some comedians of
supporting yeah yeah I guess I actually
misspoke when I said this is the
universal comedian approach it's the
universal good comedians response to
that I think so basically every comedian
that I see defending that isn't worth
shit yeah I agree
so yeah it's um it's fucking terribly
well even though there was something I
heard on the dr. Laura show I listened
to her for a laugh where they there was
someone in a university a Catholic
University defending same-sex marriage
just being like I believe me I've just
been a man and got thrown out of class
and called a bigot and hatred and all
this defending cat the Catholic stance
so not you said defending same-sex
marriage
oh sorry defending traditional marriage
oh sorry like old school marriage okay
and the teacher was like that's hateful
how dare you like well okay maybe but
why not debate it you know not figure it
out on this kid guy or just let that
person think that yeah well you care
yeah so interesting interesting I know
the world is it's a very interesting
place comedians actually defend Oh get
you the political correctness stuff I
really like I've not I've UFC just see
one good one it's always somebody who
who basically walks around with a lot of
feelings in their comedy so so like they
want that defended you know that that's
kind of their what they carry around is
that they're they're they're very
sensitive
which is fine um but I haven't really
seen many working comics no no working
Meena and also where do you draw the
line like how do you know what's not
going to offend anybody what's the safe
joke I might talk tell jokes about
balloons or is there some kind of
balloon League that's gonna get mad cuz
I'm harming the integrity of balloons
you know let's yeah it's just it goes on
and on
there's no I know oh it makes me crazy
it's a topic that makes me crazy it
makes me crazy too anyway go see it
can't we take a joke it's out